less than 24 hours after saying a final
good-bye to his brother the lowness
floyd is fighting for his legacy an
urgent rallying cry to washington I'm
tired I'm tired of pain pain you feel
when you watch something like that when
you watch your big brother who you
looked up to for your whole life die die
begging for his mom I'm here to ask you
to make it stop stop the pain stop us
being tired George called for help and
he was ignored please listen to the call
I'm making to you now to the cause of
our family and the cars ringing out the
streets across the world the treatments
of George Floyd ignited global outrage
the police response to protests only
added fuel to the fire
eleven cities have now banned chokeholds
mr. fluids family want more than just
that given the incidents that have led
to this moment in time it should be
mandatory for police officers to wear
body cams and should be considered
obstruction of justice to turn them off
like a black box data recorder in an
airplane body cams replace competing
narratives with a single narrative the
truth there are some shifts already the
Minneapolis Police Department has now
pulled out of contract negotiations with
the Union to try and focus on major
reform but Republicans are warning
against dismantling or disbanding any
forces in America policing is a very
local thing with local worries and
President Trump is firmly pushing a
law-and-order message in his supporters
claim breaking up law enforcement would
be irresponsible and dangerous the
graphic nature of one man's death has
given new life to a movement now it's
diverse and it is demanding and
achieving change
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington